dans ce gouvernement rires heisser car
38 estiment qu'il serait peut-être
préférable d'arrêter de faire de la
politique sur tous les sujets bien la
politique que nous allons en faire
justement pour commenter ce sondage
quentin one pound france info le monde
sur la perception qu'ont les français du
rassemblement naturel regarder ce
premier graphique où l'on voit les
courbes qui se croisent
c'est à dire qu'il y a aujourd'hui une
majorité de français qui considèrent que
le rassemblement national peut arriver
au pouvoir un jour en france
c'est un chiffre qui vous paraît
surprenant guillaume bernard alors non
parce qu'on n'y a été je dirais d'une
certaine manière préparé il suffit de
comparer ce qui s'est passé en 2002
lorsque jean-marie le pen a été au
second tour de la présidentielle il ya
eu des manifestations monstres
manifestants je dirais que le fait que
les gens ne l'approuvé pas pour le
deuxième tour 2010 est où marine le pen
a été donc au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle il n'y a eu aucune
manifestation donc il y à l'intégration
de la part de nos compatriotes du fait
que c'est une force politique qui jouent
le jeu des élections et qui battait
moment où elle jouait des élections elle
est susceptible de gagner
cela dit le fait que les français
partent du principe que c'est un parti
qui pourrait arriver au pouvoir
ça ne veut pas dire un qui le souhaitent
ni même qu'il va arriver
effectivement à gagner parce que là il
faut quand même regarder les choses en
face et l'a peut-être que les gens du
rassemblement national en sont
conscients mais ne le disent quand même
pas trop fort ils ont fait 11 millions
de voix au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle mais il présente que 430
liste aux municipales 11 millions de
voix uniquement 430 liste alors qu'il en
avait présenté six ans en 2014
c'est le signe que il ya quand même pas
encore beaucoup de gens qui sont près de
faire preuve d'un certain courage parce
qu'objectivement être candidat du
rassemblement national c'est faire
preuve d'un certain courage social il ya
encore pas beaucoup de gens qui sont
prêts je dirais à le à le à passer le
pas et à se présenter aux élections donc
voilà on est dans une situation ambiguë
ce chiffre et je termine là dessus ne
m'étonne pas trop parce que vous le
savez il ya un certain nombre de
propositions alors de la droite au sens
large du terme
droite modérée droite nationale qui sont
pleinement majoritaire dans l'opinion
publique à plus de 60 70 % mais dès
qu'elles sont étiquetés quand elles sont
présentées en aveugle dès qu'elles sont
étiquetés l air est reine elles
deviennent minoritaires
donc moi c'est ce que j'ai dit notamment
dans la guerre à droite c'est que si la
droite veut arriver au pouvoir et de
manière pérenne
il faut qu'elle se recompose au delà des
actuels partis politiques ligne de
fracture ne passe pas entre les parties
mais au sein des partis est donc
effectivement je ne crois pas que le rn
en tant que tel arrive au pouvoir mais
que la droite recomposée puisse y
arriver et renvoyer emmanuel macron à
ses études
ça je crois que c'est tout à fait
possible oui et pour conforter votre
démonstration voici un autre
enseignement de ce sondage
effectivement les deux tiers des
français se disent en désaccord avec les
idées défendues par le rassemblement
national donc dès lors qu'elles sont
étiquetés quand même beaucoup plus qu'il
ya 20 ans où il y avait un taux
d'adhésion y compris chez les électeurs
du fn qui était très bas alors que là le
taux d'adhésion des électeurs du fn est
d'environ 80% 80 à 85% et la 26% des
français qu'ils l'approuvent
c'est quand même à un car on peut
peut-être monter à un tiers avec les
marges d'erreur à 30%
donc pour le pour le coup effectivement
il ya quand même une progression des
idées du fn dans l'opinion publique
française
ce qu'il ya vous fait le même constat il
ya une sorte de banalisation entre
guillemets tn gérard delà des idées du
rassemblement national
pas vraiment gens que banalisation et
progression c'est pas la même chose tout
à fait et je dirais justement pas qu'ils
aient une banalisation des idées du
rassemblement national
au contraire pour moi ce sondage est un
peu décevant pour le rassemblement
national
reprenons un peu le contexte est ce qui
s'est passé marine le pen arrive 2e de
l'élection presse de la dernière
élection présidentielle le rassemblement
national arrive premier de la dernière
élection européenne et pourtant il ya
que 56% des gens qui pensent que le
rassemblement national peut un jour
arriver au pouvoir c'est extrêmement
faible un parti qui est le premier parti
d'opposition lors des grandes élections
nationales a vocation à être vu
comme pouvant gouverné par la majorité
une large majorité de français donc non
ya pas de banalisation du rassemblement
national de marine le pen et s'est vidée
et c'est plutôt inquiétant pour marine
le pen j'ajoute que un récent sondage à
demande dans un récent sondage en a
demandé aux français s'ils souhaitaient
que le prochain second tour au pot d'une
nouvelle fois emmanuel macron à marine
le pen
huit français sur dix répondent non
alors on peut dire ils veulent bien
marine le pen mais ils veulent pas
emmanuel macron ça peut être ça la
lecture du son actuel moi je crois pas
je crois que pour marine le pen
aussi ce sondage est un avertissement il
n'y a pas vraiment d'appétence
aujourd'hui des français pour un pays
dirigé par le front national
le houleux rassemblement national alors
que moi j'ai pas tout à fait je peux
vous le dire pourquoi j'ai bien tout à
fait voilà je veux je vous savez je
quand j'ai vu quand je vous avais posé
cette question je me suis dit tiens si
j'avais fait partie des interrogés et je
me suis dit si j'avais fait partie des
interrogés par mbia 5 ans et qu'on
m'aurait posé la question est-ce que
vous pensez que le front national peut
arriver au pouvoir
j'aurais répondu non on me reposer cette
question hier j'aurais répondu oui merci
non non jamais jamais de la vie non mais
voyez j'aurai je n'aurais pas répondu de
la même manière et moi je crois que il
faut essayer de comprendre ça alors
effectivement vous avez raison ça veut
pas dire que les gens ils ne souhaitent
pas la preuve 80% ne veulent pas d'un
remake de de la dernière présidentielle
au deuxième tour mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que finalement le la
possibilité ancrée que le l'extrême
droite arrive au pouvoir
elle s'enracine dans quoi elle
s'enracine dans un espèce de
de désespoir total sur l'incapacité de
nos gouvernants à répondre aux attentes
et aux à régler les principaux problèmes
auxquels on est confrontés le le
quinquennat de françois hollande a été
un quinquennat de désespoir total pour
les gens qui espéraient un changement
qui espérait davantage de justice
sociale qui espérait que cela choque
voilà oui il espéré j'espère un peu plus
de voix là et la brutalité la brutalité
sociale du quinquennat de emmanuel
macron elle va elle va dans le même sens
c'est à dire qu'elle elle crée du
désespoir elle crée de la résignation et
finalement oui un certain nombre de gens
dans ce contexte disent eh bien oui
c'est possible que ça arrive mais je
vous dis pas que à leur assemblée
nationale n'a aucune chance d'arriver au
pouvoir
je vous dis que pour moi sa position de
premier parti d'opposition est une
position fragile et très fragile par
rapport à ce qu'elles auraient pu être
des réactions en cascade de nos
internautes celle de racers car 38,6
emmanuel macron continue à n'écouter
personne
tout est possible ce qui fait un peu et
qu est ce que vous disiez gilles smadja
chardon bleu lui dit le problème c'est
que quand ils y seront
puis mais ça à l'indicatif ils ne seront
pas mieux que les autres
nathan 770 considère que tant que marine
le pen est à la tête du fn cela
n'arrivera pas claudius 15 qui rappelle
que le ratio national à des procédures
judiciaires en cours avec trois petits
points lourde de sous-entendus babineau
le rn aurait de grandes chances
d'arriver au pouvoir dans un système à
l'américaine mais avec le système
électoral français s'est compliqué et
c'est un petit peu ce que pense aussi
même assez clairement r34 qui nous dit
le système électoral à deux tours est un
vrai rabot pour le rassemblement
national je vis des 23 bleus regard
d'une journaliste politique aiguisé
depuis
17 la droite s'est effondré la gauche
avait explosé à la présidentielle mais
depuis 2010 est la droite s'est effondré
et la france a soumises recule recule
recule et fait plus du tout les scores
qu'elle faisait au moment la
présidentielle et des législatives donc
ça veut dire que seule opposition ou à
peu près marine le pen ne fait que ses
performances là qui je suis d'accord
avec etienne ne sont pas très bonnes et
en plus sont moins bonnes que celles
qu'elle faisait précisément en 2017 1
j'ai pris trois items capacité de
rassembler elle a reculé de 6 points à
elle passée de 42 % en 2010 est à 36 %
aujourd'hui
elle ferait une bonne présidente de
vente aux sondés alors là à les deux
points en dessous 22% disent oui
aujourd'hui ils étaient 24 % à dire oui
en 2017 comprends leur problème car 9%
ce qui est aussi une baisse par rapport
aux deux dernières années
donc toutes ses performances et ses sons
sont en baisse elle n'a pas rattrapé ce
qu'elle avait perdu à cause du deuxième
tour de la présidentielle et notamment à
cause du débat en termes d'image en
termes d'adhésion à ses idées
et quand on pose la question est ce que
vous croyez qu'elle peut néanmoins
arrivée au pouvoir
passez à la question qui est posée la
question qui est posée est ce que vous
pensez que le rassemblement national
peur car depuis ça semble déjà pareil je
pense que les gens ont tendance à
avancer
pour l'instant c'est là où je voulais en
venir c'est que vous avez à président de
la république qui met en scène son duel
avec marine le pen et le risque que
marine le pen
le rassemblement national arrive au
pouvoir absolument à chaque élection et
entre les élections il ne pense qu'à ça
il ne parle que de ça je suis même
étonnée que pas davantage de gens soient
convaincus qu'un petit mois et la raison
que c'est à venger imminent de deux
petits points peut-être qu'ils méritent
notre attention
on va voir au municipal si les maires
sortants et rennes sont réélus parce
qu'évidemment il ya une critique est
généralement fait vis-à-vis du du du
rassemblement national c'est je dirais
le fait qu'il ne serait pas crédible aux
affaires si les maires sont réélus il
semblerait qu'il devrait l'être qu'il
devrait l'être
après il ya un délice au sens élargi
parce qu'il ya des lys où il ya des
alliances eux pensent à ce même en anjou
qui sont aussi des listes je dirais sans
étiquette mais qui sont des leasers
rassemblement de la droite
est ce que les maires seront réélus ou
pas ça ça sera quand même un signe sur
la capacité je dirais à aller avoir
acquis une certaine crédibilité
et puis il ya un deuxième point voilà
qui paraît très important c'est que
marine le pen de manière très prématuré
ces annonces et candidate à la
présidentielle elle cherchera
certainement à l'être avec ou sans le
rassemblement national
ça chante la force politique elle est
susceptible de disparaître avec ses
enjeux financiers judiciaire mais il est
certain que l'organisation fait la
droite du spectre politique peut d'ici
là se réorganiser pour proposer une
candidature alternative qui n'auraient
pas pour but de se substituer à marine
le pen
mais qui aurait pour but de se
substituer à emmanuel macron est donc là
effectivement je crois que ça c'est une
des des perspectives qu'elle n'a pas du
tout envisagée elle s'est très
rapidement annoncé candidate pour
essayer de couper l'herbe sous le pied à
d'autres candidatures potentielles
faisant le rassemblement des
conservateurs et des populistes ce
qu'elle n'a pas compris c'est que il
peut ya voir l'émergence d'une
candidature qui serait une candidature
non pas pour se substituer à elle au
second tour mais pour être contrait le
second tour en prenant la place
d'emmanuel macron il nous reste quelques
minutes pour parler peut-être un peu de
poésie si vous le voulez bien
il ya 22 ans déjà l'incontournable jack
lang créait le printemps des poètes
nous sommes donc à cette édition qui
commence la semaine prochaine la 22e du
nom